not so easy to sort out who's the good
ones and who's the bad one sort of like
we you were talking about these people
that have the simplistic idea that all
you have to do is get Donald Trump high
on DMT and he's gonna see the light yeah
it's not necessarily the case not
necessarily the case yeah I think this
be wasted on him I think we would have
to do at least an indwelling catheter
maybe two or three hours of continuous
DFP sorry wrong wrong term it's very
very Freudian he's ready to go through
his dick right that is hilarious
not not that will go through the vein
the first time somebody the way to get
it maybe the way to get it to him is
some perfect Russian robot [__] doll who
just locks him up and you know right
when he gets inside there you go she
gets them in full guard locks it in
place and you know catheter like
delivery yeah maybe they can program it
like like DMT like little nanobots that
go right through the penis hole ready to
the system they just run out of her
right in there he's wool he just takes
off but again there has to be something
there somebody animals I have an effect
please so many anime I know there's
somebody out there that wants to that's
does do it way to do it
just some perfect superhot ten Russian
hooker looking chick no offense to
Russian hookers right or Donald Trump